do you think there's any doubt that  Mohammed bin Salman was it was involved  in this murder I look at it this way I  personally think he directed it I do not  have access to a smoking gun I think he  directed it but even if he did which I  don't think is a case he's responsible  for the agency that carried out the  killing and he's taken no ownership of  it if the CEO of your network something  terrible happens the CEO owns it and  that to me regardless again I think he  directed it I think he knew all about it  I think his half-brother lured him into  the consulate but but even if that's not  the case even you say he is responsible  for what happened and we've caused him  to take no ownership whatsoever of that  so your your point sounds like it is  it's effectively it doesn't matter  whether it's not a smoking gun does not  matter